every story feels fully fleshed out
fully realized and it every single one
is a very satisfying conclusion - yeah
for me for the Dylan Baker storyline I
see that with my dad all the time I
can't tell you how many kids in school I
personally got to decapitate yeah okay
yeah it was a lose a blast yeah I have
murdered so many people mean I was just
that boring kid when I was younger we
used to just carve like regular pumpkins
see it I would have murdered you I
[Music]
reject nation I'm growing up the
worthies right if anyone has hair that
you do one thing wrong my hair you do
like this and then sewing the hole
decides to go all right you do like
another look here idea I got this like
drug cartel appreciate that Perry Perry
never office here today people I wanted
to make sure to get her back on the
channel it's been so long you're a
horror freak and it's Halloween time so
might as well bring you back here how
you doing pretty well it's my favorite
time of year so how could I not be in a
good place right now
amen to that sister we were both in
Mexico for the nun catacombs haunt
experience yeah which is a total blast
we only bump into each other for like
five minutes go together and then you
guys were in another completely
different but in that different group I
was with John and I got a hang out with
a guy known as dead meet James and James
super friendly guy what an inspiring
story this to have he had only been
doing his channel at this point a couple
months ago like just a little over a
year and that's well over a million
followers the guy's a hard hard hard
hard worker and I asked him in person
since we were hanging out a bunch and
asked him in person if we could do a
reaction to one of his videos and he
said yes but Perry has never seen any of
it
excited about it I mean I've already
told you one thing that I thought this
video is gonna be that you're telling me
I'm wrong about it so I'm curious yes
now is he calls him killcount and I'm
sure plenty of you guys already seen his
videos is way bigger than this channel
it's killcount video it's more than just
killcam people get the impression it
might just be re just count the desk
that's not it we're doing one for my
favorite Halloween movie and I found out
seconds before filming with Perry that's
her favorite Halloween movie as well
trick-or-treat let's get to it I put the
headphones on yeah
now put the headphones on welcome to the
killcam where we tally up the victims in
all our favorite horror movies I'm James
a Jenice and today we're looking at
trick-or-treat
Louie tastic 2007 movie written and
directed by Michael Dougherty
trick-or-treat consists of a series of
intertwined behind sam take place on
halloween night in the fictional town of
Warren Valley Ohio a place that just
loves to get its trick-or-treat on
loosely connecting the stories is the
burlap sack kid sized entity Sam who's
happy to be in a passive observer until
he sees the spirit of Halloween being
rejected at which point he'll step in to
personally intervene although it doesn't
have any single overarching story
trick-or-treat is a true treasure of a
film not taking itself too seriously but
also never trying to be too cool with
detachment it's a sincere film that
lovingly explores various Halloween
traditions and you know what it's got a
pretty high heel counter boo boo boo
beyond the barn let's get to the kills
one of my favorite one isn't it sir
what's your favorite segment Robby robot
this lady I just the serial killer the
dead plane she blows out a
jack-o'-lantern
despite him saying it's ancient
tradition to leave them lit and takes
off a robot costume right there on the
sidewalk all this bah humbug hurry
attracts the attention of someone with a
glassy field of vision who runs across
the street towards their house happily
she finishes Dero bonding on the porch
Emma tells her man she wants to take
down the decorations right now lady are
you serious look at your house it's
literally going to take our
[Laughter]
only once you see the jabbawockee across
the street so they can real track for
you is that goes it's nothing inside the
seats that starts a terrier and knocks
her out to the side it takes a bitten
off lollipop it splits or throw with it
there's these trivial kids away get out
of here you bunch of clowns and one
becomes our first killed the movie just
shortly after her man finds her body
beneath the sheets hung up and
dismembered and with that yummy pumpkin
Molly in her mouth the opening credits
are in the style of the comic books it's
wild too like Creepshow I love Lisa
related comic series alongside the film
although I don't know that delay the
opening still gives us have you ever
seen some of the Sam shorts they're
great well earlier on TV to a news
report talking about Hanukkah bonkers
this town goes over Halloween like their
that place in hocus pocus or something
girls and changing which is weird
because he's like six but also was more
sex down in a demure Little Red Riding
Hood costume
Danielle invites the Elven cashier to a
party that night after asking when he
gets off in about 20 minutes actually
yeah right dude you're working a costume
shop on wean bra you ain't getting off
to a vampire's go to sleep on their way
to the party after bumping into garage
bar Danielle tells Lori she needs to
find a date that she's 90 year old
virgin Wow this Lily might be the topper
focus focus and Maria and Jamie seem
just as obsessed with getting that be
since they asked these random guys
loading up a news van out on dates to
the party a couple of years later at
this party's ready to roll they now
reluctantly agrees to leave Maury behind
and don't find her own date in the
streets of this crazy Halloween party
meanwhile Charlie we buy that kid from
that Sam walking down the street doing
his best Billy Corgan impersonation when
he goes to steal some candy from an
unsupervised porch she's caught
red-handed by the owner of the house
yeah
Wilkins makes them sit down
it's candy while he talks about carving
jack-o'-lanterns and other Halloween
tradition you must be a bad storyteller
because Charlie starts having a physical
you never forget what's going on there
something you forgot to do always check
your candy yeah yeah I think he forgot
to do that which is why he sits there
doubled over if you could have blood and
or chocolate I don't really see the joke
there but wolken sure is having a laugh
probably cuz he's the one who poisoned
all that chocolate that Charlie dies
watching over to Wilkins life seem
insane I guess that's one less kid to
process paperwork for at school right
Stephen Lupin's his corpse removal was
interrupted by a knock at the door it's
a trio of trick-or-treaters and they
asked him for his jack-o'-lantern it's
part of a scavenger give that's my
favorite part
yeah you don't know how much of a right
decision that was Steve you don't want
to get on that kids bad side Wilkins
goes out back and uncovers a grave
containing another body but before he
can heat Charlie's down into it he gets
interrupted again this time by a son
Billy who's just the elements goddamn
bums out about how he does work the
treating the other body in the grave
starts screaming and moving around Creek
walks over the fence and hidey-ho
neighbors mr. Wilkins asking and what
the hell is going on Wilkins is able to
talk himself out of the situation and
tries to silence the body for good but
gets interrupted once more by Billy
screaming about carving jack-o'-lanterns
and asked him to go with his dad as a
parade later no daddy has a date Billy
goes away and Wilkins seems to be in the
clear Jesus Billy you don't want
Halloween is camp
no more Halloween for you on account of
your screaming into the night sky like
that with a ghost finally clear for
really reals Wilkins takes a shovel and
delivers an overhead smack to the
shuffle bag
giving us a kill that cuts away
immediately but at least we get to see
him watering the grain that's nice
what's not nice is the way Wilkins is
mocking his own son seems real friggin
annoying with that kid so it's
troublesome when he grabs a knife and
head to downstairs with him to carve the
jack-o'-lantern we don't need two weeks
in a row with the young dead Billy's kid
so get the hell out of it Wilkins raises
his knife up and brings it down at a
powerful staff but turns out Billy's not
in danger after all I do have a cackling
question about this moment
I'll say perfectly okay to have a
question about that see nothing to worry
about here at all now we're back to
those trick-or-treaters Maci Sarah and
chip who are trick-or-treating at
another teachers home and interrupting
her swinger look at parties I on the
prize you're there for Jacqueline that
whatever is going on in that party what
is going on but [ __ ] a pig to get
enough Jacqueline it's for the good I go
to this house home LeBron who they call
an idiot savant
but honestly looks to me like she's just
dope as hell with carving pumpkins
Rayder turns on his charm cuz they gonna
be needing some of that squash over at
the town's festival of costumed fools
the lady makes out with a massive
stranger in an alleyway at the start of
every good love story their tongue
tangle stops when she lifts up her hand
to find out she's bleeding like kind of
a lot there and that this dude's got
bangs hot damn dude we got a vampire on
our hands she runs away from him and
towards the parade and a fairy I know
what you did by summer like shot but I'm
like Sarah Michelle this chick actually
makes it to safety but our victory is
short-lived since her pleading for help
is we're buffed by the grumpy Tron 9000
who mistakes her for just another drunk
hoodlum to fake blood all over her by
mask a man shows up behind her and whips
his cape over her for another off-screen
kill run money against the store they
can't just die you know like people do
all the time in public streets at crazy
Halloween parade master vampire man
walks off into the night zoom will bleed
to find another Ridge now with a wagon
full of pumpkins in tow the trick or
treater kids are led by Macy to a cliff
overlooking a rock quarry where she
wriggles them all with a Halloween story
it's a sepia-tone Sam streak did the
abandoned rock quarry that Macy and Co
are now standing it turns out the
parents were sick of dealing with their
dirty little secrets and paid the bus
driver to kill them all and would have
work too now for these meddling kids
especially this Dracula who realizes
they aren't where they should be and
tries to drive the bus home on his own
he only manages to get it moving in a
straight line start kid right off the
cliff where it falls the sinks into the
water below the eight children are
killed as their masks load away along
the surface of the water they all get
added to our list
although
server genders while the driver is fair
he makes it out and according to Macy
was never heard from again
Macy's plan is to leave 8
jack-o'-lanterns by the side of the lake
as an offering to the kids who died she
and the other two alpha most kids
descend down the elevator her and when
Rhonda and pyro mr. favorite consumer
late weather is why if you relate with
her I really shitty a jack-o'-lantern a
carver Wow go protect him then heads out
and finds herself staring at a school
bus I have something in the way this
creepy image that corroborates Macy's
pal oh right the imagery in this one
which is emerged from the water and
Rhonda runs back to the elevator where
she finds chip on the ground getting his
guts good at nom nom after she really
got was it off her blind ass gets
cornered by the creatures all wet into
chained and Rhonda falls backwards off a
ledge into some water but it's not a
killcount leaned over her and stare when
she comes to she wanders up the
creatures were just the other kids and
that chick wasn't even dead those are
probably just nasty cold hot dogs around
traitor finally learns what empathy does
that's about time these Ramblers get
rambling so they should pack it up and
leave over by the bus Maisie kicks the
last black lantern nearby into the water
which immediately proves to be a mistake
when they start hearing spooky noises
sho'nuff looks like we got some zombie
kids on our hands some giggle as they
shambled towards the four mean kids
during their retreat the chains on
Sarah's costume get hung up and she's
dragged away by the zombie bus can you
temporarily stop their pursuit to get
their murder on the other kids reached
the elevator where she has locked
herself inside safe with the final lit
Jacqueline she goes to let them in then
his all psych and hits the button to go
up by herself waving bye-bye defenders
here the kids are cornered by the
zombies and killed off screams stay very
carefully I would not Sam shows up but
it's happy to leave pronto alone well
she is true and has the Halloween spirit
with him meanwhile Laura's been walking
around looking for a date but having no
lot which is pretty hard to do you
realize mr. name is Laurie he's a little
too baby OPC Daisy for well she's on the
phone Laurie notices the masked killer
from earlier staring at and later when
she's walking to the bonfire party by
herself
he pops up out of nowhere and attacks
her slamming her up against the tree and
biting into her neck like a freak out
freak out
Danielle and the others at the party
worried about Lori's warehouse screamin
horror when a body and Lori's costume
falls from the trees when they check it
out and lift the hood they find that
it's the mass killer who's now gasping
for breath and begging them for help
Lori shows up to the party looking much
more like a little pirate wench she
tells the rest of the ladies all right
thank you baby
Maria goes don't do it takes out a snake
fangs you're not a real vampire at all
you were never a real vampire
in fact you're just a high school
principal Steven freakin will get man
you bet a busy night Steve does have a
good question though who are you people
and then he discovers for us so let's
see we got a pirate a another body line
there that's cool I guess
oh [ __ ]
it's a wide shot and there are a lot of
bodies here I actually pause this and
went through it a ton in slow motion and
all in all I think there are nine bodies
hearing Wow man guys the cast year the
big baby man and five others may be
wrong I don't this number makes sense to
me though since there are also nine
girls other than Laurie at this banger
and after all they only to date the
Laurie's day - Stephen doughnuts out
nowhere that's a hard kill counted I say
just dammit then to a sexy montage
scored by a Marilyn Manson cover of
sweet dreams are made of these the
ladies at the party shut down House of
the Haunted Hill horse and it's her back
and she and the other stars baby
horny Stephen no just terrified that's
cool you'll make a tasty snack either
way Lord he sits on Steve and Danielle I
was at the moon and victory since Lori's
finally lost her where virginity Sam
sits there and watches it all which
makes me a little worried about his
development this is not for young guys
mister we do another time job to earlier
in the night that one trio of
trick-or-treaters from the opening visit
a house and I'm gonna get scared off by
glowing eyes and growls emerging from
the dark get out here you watch clown
this is really crazy to know how do you
actually get a release - yeah good buddy
Jim Beam and everyone's favorite pastime
with burning photographs in the
fireplace well he's busy screwing it up
in Omaha lloween specials on TV
frankfurt exist window sending creeps to
the closet to fish out a frigate of
these i think this is the scariest one
done awesome punctus segment yeah got
that haunted house you don't know it's
creeping around this front yard has been
covered with jack-o'-lanterns by some
decorative pagan he'll have none of that
same doctor 50 takes a shotgun and heads
upstairs to investigate more noises in
his bedroom a pumpkin lights up and
reveals a remodeling job done by Kevin
Spacey's character and such bought that
wallpaper I was admiring the redesign I
get stabbed in the way Sam
he gives with the bag over his head and
adorable footie pajamas
looks like he's packing a candy bar full
of razor blades just for Krieg
trick-or-treat [ __ ]
Greg runs away and falls down the stairs
onto a whole bunch of candy and loose
razor blades so when he tries to get
back to do was cut up his hands my bad I
keep some yeah little grass during the
fight Creek pulls off Sam's bag mask to
reveal a skeleton based on a pumpkin
head you know what still kind of keeps
he's even cute as they bite to the
creeks lake for a tasty snack so freakin
recovers the shotgun and shoots and
Point Blank which sends them across the
room against the door when Krieg goes
buckwild with a couple extra shots the
reveals pumpkiny inner sweet make
yourself a little sampai sam recovers of
remasters now open out of his
trick-or-treating pass grab some bright
orange pumpkin lollies that he bites a
jewel left he raises the candy up high
to bring it down on creep but we get
another fake out stabbed when he just
pierces the candy bar instead what
that's all he wanted Oh Sam you're not
you when you're hungry his sweet tooth
days
behind him was Halloween close up on
those burning pictures reveals that the
reason Creek hates this damn holiday so
much is because he was the bus driver
from the rock quarry store later on
curry gets a visit from three kings and
damage the see maybe he complies with
the sacred balls of Halloween and gives
him awesome candy with the spirit of
Halloween restored the movie wraps up
its despair storylines showing an orphan
but cheerful Billy Wilkins dressed up
like his dad and handing out candy the
last kori jack-o'-lantern being pulled
in a wagon by Rhonda and the where gal
is heading home in a bootable Asian Sam
washes over at all keeping an eye on
creeks until something else catches his
not one grouchy [ __ ] robot lady blows
out her Jacqueline's you know what to do
Sam going for some Halloween law just
when you think it's all the way today
Kree gets one final knock at the door
looks like it's those meddling kids from
the school bus ready or not here they
kill file kill the movie is done in
quick flashes of a graphic novel death
as Mr curry gets his comeuppance from
the kids he killed so long ago and thus
ends our Halloween Town where lessons
were learned and kills were counted how
many kills let's find out and get to the
numbers nice touch 27 people were killed
the TV well real hard to tell around
that bonfire of the 27 I counted only
four worth even I was sixteen were male
and the seven kids besides Dracula we're
on verified either way regardless it's
pretty imbalance distribution there and
a lead one time of 82 minutes we wound
up with a kill on average over three
point zero four minutes record happy
Halloween I'll give the golden chainsaw
for coolest killed to Charlie so many of
the other kills we're off screen here we
have the Bad Santa kid puking up gallons
of blood charlie plus we see a severed
head a little later cementing is fade is
the most graphic of the film doll
machete for Leyva's kill will go to macy
chip and trader who are killed off
screen with nothing but some sound
effects to show for and that's it
trick-or-treat is the perfect film
probably it's short light and fun which
is everything a Halloween movie should
be my opinion
next month is alien I'll be covering the
original aiming quadrilogy each Friday
in November
till then I'm James age these videos
like a year old my patrons like Elsa
Gayle picks foliage so I can actually
watch it the mist is probably a good one
I wouldn't trade a brain that's
impressive
that's impressive stuff Oh many many
years ago I think is it Christmas is
Christmas her birthday present it was
the first time him and I made love and
John's really sentimental I've never
actually opened the box yeah yeah I've
never I've never opened the box because
it's a collectible is it can I wear this
mask I'm pretty sure that's the point of
it oh my god is the first time I'm over
in this box
whoa I've never opened this box before
Wow I can't I can't wear it now maybe
next Halloween maybe next Halloween
what'd you think of your first killcount
video exam me James it was very cool I
mean I'm impressed - it's a very
well-written
yes script and it's got a lot of funny
beats to it when I have a movie that
I've seen so many times over to hear
certain details that I either missed or
wasn't aware of like the idea of Quinn
the kid who plays Sam in the movie in
the dressing room yeah I had no idea I
knew what he looked like
yeah but for some reason that never
clicked for me and I actually didn't
even know I for some reason I feel like
I've never noticed when Laurie is
walking and I him I don't know he didn't
point it out but you know Halloween and
character name or never put that
together as the truth when she's walking
and then the girl in the Box gets killed
the beginning bumps in there yeah yeah I
never noticed that it till he pointed
out like oh shoot yeah Bree watches this
is why trick-or-treat is such a great
Halloween movie - one and this is
like about what he brings up a lot it's
not just about the cool kill counts he
constantly talked about how this is
basically a movie that celebrates the
importance of doing certain Halloween
traditions love the focus on that but
also in rewatching trick-or-treat
yeah there's separate stories but they
are so precisely well woven together
where it's so satisfying when you get
back to that first kill in the end there
is an art and a completion to the story
it's more than just an anthology and
it's also in terms of its structure and
it's also more than just doing like what
pulp fiction did in terms of that are
cutting around the timeline and
everything by the time you get to the
end of this you're actually wrapping up
all the stories like there's a
completion to all of them that is so
cleverly like this is one of the best
structured movies I've ever seen in John
and I we watched this about a year
before it ever came out at a theater we
had no idea we were gonna watch no it
was the thing it premiered at a festival
I think in 2007 and then didn't get
regularly 2009 we went to one of those
screenings that we couldn't get into now
because of what we do but at the time of
okay audience test I got you yeah so we
we went to one of those it was terrible
no idea we were about to watch I was so
on edge the entire time I was watching
the film especially in the finale with
Brian Cox that was insanely suspenseful
to me I love how he does these videos
because I thought it was just gonna be
kill count yeah oh you're just counting
kills and you show the deaths yeah I've
seen that before but he does here it's
it's so tightly scripted and so tightly
edited as well he's breaking down
essentially the whole movie like if
anything if there's a horror movie you
don't really care to watch it you want
to know about it you can watch one of
his videos if you happen to cover it
here you do all the Halloween movies
he's covered and you feel like you've
seen all of them because his
commentaries great his jokes seem
natural they don't seem like they're
trying to be too funny the editing style
to it as well of cutting back and forth
between him I think his silage is
insanely impressive it's cool seeing the
graphic at the end to just the idea of
the the big picture I mean you know what
what does it really mean that like less
women died in this movie than men but
it's just fun to kind of take a step
back and see the big picture results I
thought you would like that too because
you like to do like your box numbers
crunchy the more specific video and
trick-or-treat the one thing I did have
a question about it yeah I wonder if we
both had the same question about wrote
something down when something crossed my
mind with yeah whether he shows that the
dead kid's head to his son and he's
killing the body he seems like he's
trying to keep it a secret kid from his
son Dylan Baker that's his name Dylan
Baker he seems like he's trying to keep
it a secret but then he shows he shows
the head so I'm like why why was he
acting like he was trying to keep a
secret or know if he was trying to keep
a secret from the kid more so than
trying to keep a secret from the
neighbor because ya know it's drawing
attention to what he's doing that's
right Brian Cox is kind over yeah the
kid knows it's a tradition for the
holiday Halloween so it's like they've
probably done it before my question was
if that's an additional body but that's
an additional kill maybe this is just
how I'm miss reading the scene and have
always just had this in mind but I
always thought that that was the the kid
in there and that when he goes like that
that's him severing the head I might
have just completely misread that and
you know just always had that in my mind
since my first viewing especially cuz
James did count when he turned out the
chocolate as a kill what James says is
that he's got an additional body in the
backyard I always thought that that was
the kid's body and by slam yeah shovel
down he was that's the moment where he
takes his head off but maybe I just
misread it given what this character
does the entire movie odds are he has
killed more ah okay okay so your
question is was that an additional yeah
all right I got you I think sure
Gertrude is is so underrated
weirdly if they had just waited a few
more years it might have got her in a
theater release it probably would have
done really well because this has become
a cult hit oh absolutely
like a lot of people in the horror
community really love this film cuz it's
not just a good horror movie it's a good
film
it's use of practical effects are so
awesome the design of Sam when they're
turning into werewolves that always
makes me like are you know if you like
I've been watching the show Supernatural
with John there's one scene with a
that what are those called shaker okay
nobody's shape-shifting he's tearing off
his skin we're thinking like Terminator
2 when he tears off his forearm even
though I know they're not dying it's
still like insanely disturbing to me and
when they do that here it's very
disturbing to me every single time I
watch it I don't know why I just always
gets under my skin it always feels like
a movie with maximum production value to
me it's like I imagine they didn't have
endless money to spend on all these
effects and all the crazy stuff but it's
like what they do with the money they
have and also how he shoots it I think
enhances the the practical work they
have on staff so more absolutely a lot
of times these anthology films that kind
of feel like they go on a little too
long yeah are they like overstaying
their welcome well cuz then it gets that
effect like I don't want to throw ABCs
of death under the bus but I am gonna
throw ABCs and path under the bus
because it's that effect where you're
watching and you're like oh I'm only yet
see yeah exactly yeah not to say that C
isn't good in that but I can't even
remember what C is but but this movie
why this movie doesn't have that all
stories are fantastic and they all it
goes back to why they all flow so well
into one another to you it's like you
never really have that moment to like
pick your head up and like have a breath
for air and think to yourself well how
many more segments are there yeah they
all flow so it's especially surprising
for like what do you say the films like
82 minutes or so yeah it's really it's
so sure but it doesn't feel that short
that's not a bad thing here the runtime
of this movie has been a problem in my
life often because do you remember when
fEARnet was around and they used a
24-hour marathon because it's such a
short movie I could sit there and watch
like yeah and not even realize every
story feels fully fleshed out fully
realized and it every single one is a
very satisfying conclusion to yeah for
me for the Dylan Baker storyline I used
to do it with my dad
all the time I can't tell you how many
kids in school I personally got a
decapitate yeah okay yeah it was a blast
yeah I have murdered so many people mean
I was just that boring kid when I was
younger we used to just carve like
regular pumpkins see it I would have
murdered you I don't get it
matter of fact maybe when we're done
no more Perry Nemiroff at Collider
videos and on her own channel what you
guys should go subscribe to you right
now well what is like we've been we've
been talking to many sincere talk here
about trick-or-treat throw it's a weird
joke alright guys well Demi James the
guy could really use some help
channels dying gosh you know and he
could really use a boost from the real
rejects he averages barely any views per
video is very lazy stuff he just watches
movies and breaks it down like this is
real work reacting to his work and then
talking about it and the film literally
just give him a pity subscribe go do it
right now he doesn't deserve it but
might as well do no I actually very
friendly gentleman I can't wait to see
him as six months from now where it's
been a year and a half in the game and
he's insanely cocky because he's on his
path he's right through still he's still
in the humble face but you'll be in the
cocky path soon buddy weird out your
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell Perry Nemiroff go
check out her channel got some awesome
stuff on there she the first man review
of my brother yeah be Kawai who is also
failing on YouTube and box office
predictions videos those are awesome
awesome stuff see you guys